for me it does begin with us you know a
kind of non corporate approach to life
it begins with a world that is more
peaceful more just it begins with the
mantra which informed the Obama
campaign's best part in my view which
was the organizing from below which was
about respect inclusion opportunity
empowerment and I those are attributes
of a left and progressive community that
I believe in and independence is what
the nation has been about for 143 years
so that we've never been as we stated in
our founding statement in 1865 the organ
of any party and that is where you find
I think a strong basis for being a true
free-thinking liberal lefty progressive